So good morning everyone. Thank you for
being here so early in the morning and
um to be able to be the few ones who
pass security to uh to be actually be
here. Um I'm uh I'm Guiam and I will
talk tell you about uh Jen Media in
general. Um
like uh so this is this is my life as u
as Nano Banana sees it. Um basically I I
joined Google six years ago. I used to
be a video game producer before. Um, I
initially worked on Stadia, the
streaming game company that uh product
that uh that we killed as so many other
product um and uh and I've been at
DeepMind for two years now. Uh and uh as
I worked as a um what we called a
developer advocate. So if you're not
familiar with what the developer
advocate basically my my job is to make
sure that uh when whenever we release
things or whatever we release uh you
guys the developers have everything you
need to work with uh our products. So
you you need documentations you need
code samples you need um demos uh now
there are new things that you need as
well like skills and prompt guides and
and things like that. So making sure
that you can you can start right away
and it works. Um and on the other on the
other side when I'm talking internally
I'm that's reason why it's advocate
because I'm advocating for the
developers and trying to bring some uh
let's say common sense to the internal
teams and making sure that what we what
we release makes sense uh in the in the
real world and it's not uh entirely
developed uh for Google by by Google. Um
a very good example of that is the
imagine models. Uh when we release when
we add like imagine and nano banana the
each model has it add its own set of API
it doesn't make any dam sense like you
like a normal developer should be able
to just swap the model name and it
works. Uh and I've I fought quite a long
time for for that. I never managed to
win but in the end I think the Imagine
brand is doesn't exist anymore so I kind
of win by default. Um but yeah you see
you see the kind of uh the kind of work
I I have to do on a daily basis.
Um as I said I'm mostly working on the
gen media model. So we like um and
that's why the talk is about uh gen
media. So uh if you if you look at the
world your phone and anything like
medias are everywhere. So uh you have
like images, videos, sounds uh
everywhere. So it's really core in our
world and um and that was at the core of
what DeepMind is is building with with
our models. Um we like you you you're
starting to to hear with uh with Lan's
new startup about world model but that's
exactly what we have been trying to
build at Google for uh since the
beginning. Um and our vision of world
model is that it's a it's a model that
as its name imply understands the world
but meaning it can ingest uh as many
modalities as possible. So sound,
videos, audio, uh sensors, uh whatever
kind of all five senses and then um
outputs or like uh yeah talks in in
different as many different modalities
as possible. So audio, text and and so
on and and much more in the in the
future. Um and we we tend to to have
like specific models. uh we have our
image generation models, we have our
video generation models, but deep down
the the goal is really to have like one
models that encompass all of that. It's
just that for release purposes, it's
easier to ship specific models and to
always update the main model and like
have risks of uh breaking something else
at the same time. But like uh a quick uh
a quick story like when we released
Gemini 1.0, it was two years ago. It it
seems it feels like it was like years
ago like aons ago but uh the first uh
Gemini model Gemini 1.1 was meant to be
multimodel because all of our models
have always been multimodel but since I
guess the testing was not finished or
what whatever reason I wasn't there yet.
Um they they remove the uh image
understanding the multimodel
understanding inputs from the model. So
the 1.1 was not multimodel and then 1.5
came and then this one was multimodel in
and I think that was the first one that
was uh that was doing that and which
once again is crazy like it's it was a
year and a half ago and now you don't
imagine working with model that is not a
multimodel one. Um but still when you
were using that that one very often you
were giving it an image and it was
telling you oh I'm sorry I'm just a LLM
I can't I can't deal with images and
that just because some of the training
that was me that was added at at the end
of 1.0 that was oh you know how to deal
with image but if you are asked don't
use it though some of that training was
still remaining in 1.5 and coming up for
from time to time. So that was uh yeah
that kind it was kind of annoying for
until we we shipped we switch up to um
to 2.0.
Um so as I said we don't only have the
Gemini models in um at Deep Mind. So we
have all of the image video music
generations. We have a couple of other
very specific models. We have the
robotics one that is kind of a
multimodel one as well because the
vision is very important for for
robotics. Uh we have a bunch of agents
that we are shipping. I think this year
is going to be the the year of agents,
the real one. Last year was everybody
talking of agents. This year is the is a
year where we are actually going to
build agents and we have the open
models. And I forgot to update the slide
because it's not GMA 3 anymore. It's
Gemma 4 since last week and then bunch
of uh research models like alpha evolve
alpha genome weather next and so on.
That's very like very specific for
research purposes.
Um just on the on on gen media we've
shipped things uh on average more than
every month. Uh on on the wall if you
just take all of deep mind we are
shipping things every five days uh on
average some some weeks we're shipping
two or three things and if we had all of
the small small features we're shipping
multiple times per week. So it's uh
that's why I'm I and most of my
colleagues are very busy because we
always have like new things to to
document and talk about.
Um so very quickly about the new things
that we shipped recently. U Nano Banana,
we shipped Nanobanana 2 uh which has uh
new spec ratios uh from uh
uh like 520 pixels to to 4K. Um it has
search grounding as uh as you all know
but it also have like image grounding.
So if you can ask it to search for
images on the web and use those images
as grounding so that it knows uh uh like
yeah it has better knowledge about what
what things look like. It's very useful
for architectural stuff for example for
uh animals and and things like that. uh
there's a lot of
rules internal that I I was not able to
to all figure out but for example
buildings they have to be old enough
otherwise there are legal reasons we
can't use the images so um but but it's
still uh very useful when when it works
uh we have the VO models you heard about
V3 VO 3.1 we um we just released last
week uh V3.1 light which is our cheapest
model. Uh I think it's 5 cent per
second. So 40 40 cent for for one video
which is very cheap. And the idea is
that you can iterate on um on on the
prompt that way and then upscale
afterwards. Um and we have LIA which is
our music generation model that we um
that we released uh two weeks ago. um
and with which you can create either 30
second clips or full songs of 3 minutes.
I will I will show you demos of all of
that afterwards. That's the point of the
of the session anyway. And uh but uh
there's also another LIA model that uh
people don't know about that is called
LIA real time and that's actually my my
favorite model. Um, and this one is
basically you you you create music as
well, but it's not a uh a diffusion
model like the others where you just
give a prompt and you get uh something
out of it. It's uh it's a predict model.
So, which means it's uh it's it's
basically a live model. So, it creates
music and it's continue to create music
uh in real time until you stop it and
you can just send you prompts and it
will like a DJ mix and like swap to the
to the new music in real time and real
time two seconds. Uh but uh but then uh
and that's that's quite fun to play
with. Uh if we have time at the end, I
will I will show you a demo.
Um but as I said uh this is meant to be
a workshop. So the goal is for you to to
play with with the models and for me to
show you codes instead of slides. So um
this is the content that we're going to
use. Uh that's this one as well. If you
can read what I wrote. Um,
and if that doesn't work, just tell me.
>> Are you all in? No.
>> Not.
>> No, it doesn't work.
Oops.
Let me let me triple check that the link
works.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I have a typo.
>> Cool. Um, are you all in? Okay. So uh
full disclosure before we start uh this
is using gen media models which means
they are all paid models. So uh running
the the notebook is going to cost you
something like $1. Uh and you can just
keep the video generation because that's
a most of the of the cost of that of
that $1.
So um the Yep.
I can zoom in a bit.
Um
so the the goal of that uh that content
I prepared is to illustrate a book using
the different uh gen media models. So
the what we're going to do is that we're
going to uh to take a book that uh is uh
is an open- source one that I took on
the Gutenberg uh li online library and
basically we are going to use uh Gemini
to come up with prompts and then the gen
media to create uh the content for the
prompts so that we can we will have
images of the characters imaging of the
scenes uh videos of those uh those
things and and so on.
Um and uh and that uh that example comes
from what we call the cookbook. So we
have uh we have this GitHub repo where
we are posting examples of uh like both
quick start guides to explain how to use
a new model or how to use a new feature
and also full like full-fledged examples
like this one on how to go further and
to mix different features into uh into
content. So if you if you're looking for
ideas that's that's a good place to to
check uh what you can do with the
models.
So um basically introduction uh billing
um so let's start. So the first thing is
that you need to install the SDK. Um you
need the latest one because of music
generation that was uh shipped last week
uh two weeks before. So actually you
need the next one.
Um
so it's starting
and I should have done that. Um and you
will need an API key if you don't have
an API key from uh from AI studio and
you need as I said you need that API key
to be a paid one. Um, if you don't have
a paid API key, you can still use the
image generation examples by using the
Nano Banana one model, which has a free
tier. So, you can just swap the model
we're going to use for for this one. And
why is that so slow?
I think
>> the
I think it's good.
>> Okay. So then I'm just loading the uh
the API key. Um, and I'm creating the
client, the genai client. And you can
see there I added this part that you we
don't add in all of our examples. That
is basically the auto retry uh thing
because like if we're using Nano Banana
2 at the moment, especially in the
evening when the US wakes up, uh, the
model can be overloaded. So that's
that's bas that part basically says that
it's going to be automatically retrying
uh five times after two seconds.
>> Um a bunch of imports and then uh we're
going to select all of the models that
we are going to use. So uh in this case
um 3.1 flash image preview which is nano
banana 2 uh Gemini 2.5 flash
>> let's use
>> 3.3 free flash instead uh Lia clip to
create uh 30 second music clips and um
and the TTS model this one the pro one
>> so and I added this checkbox box that
should have been false by default, but I
made a mistake yesterday evening. Uh
just so that you can you if you you you
won't be able you should not be able to
run the notebook by mistake if you don't
want to pay.
Um then just uh I'm just setting limits
here because uh uh like a book can be
can have a lot of chapters, lots of
characters and that can be quite long to
uh to to generate. So that's why I set
up limits on how how many we want for
the demo purposes and ghost uh purposes
as well.
>> So um as I said we are going to use an
open source book uh that's uh will the
wind in the willows uh from Kenneth
Graham that I don't remember reading but
I think in the UK it's quite well known.
Um so basically I'm just downloading it
from the Gutenberg project and uh and
here I'm using uh client file upload
which is um you you might know that we
have basically two ways of using the
Gemini a the Gemini models. We have the
AI studio Gemini API way and you have
vertex. And the main difference between
the two and I can maybe that's a good
time to switch to this slide up.
Um but uh we you know at Google we like
to basically create multiple products
that are doing the same thing and
confuse our users. That's kind of our uh
moto. Um so that we're doing the same
with with AI. So we have a bunch of uh
but actually when you think about it
it's it can make more sense. So on the
on the left we have what we call the
cons consumers app. So it's a fully
developed uh app for for that are easy
to use for anybody who is not technical.
So you can do plenty of things with the
with Gemini but you you have you're
lacking as a developer you might be
frustrated because you're lacking
control about which models which
features which parameters are being
used. And on the other end we have uh
vertex AI which is uh the exact
opposite. It's meant for enterprise. So
you have a lot of control. You can
control on which data center it runs.
You can uh you have control about your
buckets, who has access to what and and
so on. The only thing is that it comes
with like like with great powers come
with great responsibilities. So you it's
it can be a pain for people to start
there. So that's why we have the Gemini
developer API that are kind of a middle
ground for for developers uh where you
can just create an API key and then
start using the um the models right
away. with which comes with al security
uh risks as well that if your key leaks
every anybody can can just use it. So um
and and AI studio is like is is a kind
of the the same vein that it's uh it's
meant to be a place where you can test
the model and uh and play with them uh
as easily as possible. And the cool
thing is that we have the same SDK
between Vertex AI and developer API. So
you can swap from another one to
another. So there's no wrong place to
start playing with the models because
you can always change. Um and then we
can skip that and I can go back here
because actually what I was going to say
is that we actually have a few
differences between when you're using
Vertex and when you're using uh the
Gemini API. Um because uh like the the
goal of the Gemini API is basically to
hide all of the complexity from Vert.ex.
And one of those complexity is creating
buckets, creating ACL for the buckets,
giving rights and and and all of those
things. So the Gemini API have has that
uh that API that calls that is called
file upload. And basically what it does
is that you upload a file and then it's
easily accessible from the model.
Um
so I upload the file and then I I will
use uh I will use what we call chat
mode. So basically uh what it does is
that it's it chains requests and it
keeps the history of it uh so that it's
uh it's easier to to keep all of the
context and in this case it's going to
be good because we are going to feed the
wall book to uh to the model uh thanks
to the the large context window and
that's why uh it's going to be useful in
in in our case because um I'm going to
run that while I talk. Um it's uh it's
going to be useful because we like for
image generation it's it's always a good
idea to know what's what have been
generated pre previously so it it keeps
the same styles and and things like
that. Um I'm also going to use
structured output so that we like we
have a structure about what the the
model outputs and we we can we can talk
the same language which is going to be
very simple. I want it to generate
prompts and I want the prompts to have a
name so that we know it's if it's a
chapter, a character or something and
the prompt in itself.
So I'm just creating like uh
initializing the the chat client uh with
the response type uh JSON the scheme
that I that I'm providing and something
that we shipped yesterday that is a
service tier priority. So don't do that
yourself. I think you should remove that
line. Um what what it does is that it
basically uh it's it's yeah we shipped
that last week. So we have uh three
service tiers. You have the normal one.
You're paying the normal price. You're
like in the queue with everybody else
and we have another one that is called
flex and that's basically I don't care
if that takes a long time but I want to
pay to to pay less. So you're going to
have a 50% discount but your request can
be uh can be delayed and and so on up to
a few minutes and on the other end you
have priority where you are going to pay
twice the price but at the same time
you're you're kind of guaranteed that
it's going to be fast because you will
you will have the fast track like in the
airport or anywhere anywhere else. So
yesterday I added that and I'm I'm going
to use that to be certain that it works
well for me. But for you, you might want
to save a few bucks and not add that
here.
>> How much more expensive?
>> So twice.
>> Twice. Okay.
>> Yeah.
Um and I'm not sure it works with VO
anyways, which is the most expensive
ones uh of the model and uh no with yet.
So
>> Okay. Yeah. Um, so anyway, so I'm
starting with I've created this this
chart and what I'm going to do is to
send it the first message that basically
says uh I'm feeding you the the wall
book. Uh I don't need to do anything
with with the book yet, but you have it.
It's in your context and instructions we
will follow.
And then we are going to define a style.
Uh usually I just set nothing and then I
let uh Gemini come up with its own
style. Uh but then but I'm getting tired
of having exactly the same size same
style always. So let's write something
um
uh
a colorful
um building block star.
Um,
well,
let's let's go with that. Let's see
what's how it goes. So, I'm just
defining a style. And by the way, if
you're using collab, these uh collab has
those things that they called um they
call magics. And that's kind of nice to
to create those notebooks and to have
the like forms that people can fill. And
that's just uh that fits into the into
the code.
Um then some system instructions uh to
to uh to direct the model uh like to uh
into the kind of images that we want
because the problem I had at the
beginning when I was working on those
examples is whenever you ask a portrait
image and the model knows it's about a
book, it tends to create like cover
pages and to add a title and that's I
didn't want those styles or to create uh
ones with different panels and I didn't
want that either. So, uh just that's
just what the system sections are about.
And then like we can start uh working
and basically uh I'm going to ask it to
create prompts for each characters of
the book. So uh can you describe the
main characters only the adults? Uh
actually you we could remove that
because it's it was just from the
beginning of Nano Banana when you could
not generate kids images in Europe but
it's not it's not true anymore. Uh so um
you can you can create image from
nothing uh with kids but you can't edit
images with kids. That's that's a
current limitation in Europe.
But anyway, here's our uh or prompts for
for each character and then we can move
to uh creating the the the images for
for each of them. And what I'm going to
do is that I'm going to create another
chat just for the images because I don't
want to mix the the text and the and the
images output, but I want it to be a
chat so that it will have all of the
history of the previous images it
created. Um, so I'm I'm setting up with
the responsibility image, the aspect
ratio we want, the stem instructions we
decided did, and the style and priority
as as I said before. Um, and here we go.
So, here's the mole. That's nice.
Here's the uh water rat.
And that's actually way faster now that
I'm using priority. So, this works.
Um
I I could have done it uh in a better
way and like make all of the calls as
synchronous. That would have wouldn't
have worked with uh with chat mode, but
that would have been a way to to make it
faster. Um I think it's good enough. The
the toad
way bigger than the car for some reason.
>> Yeah.
Uh and then Mr. Badger. Um
yeah. So as this dark this is mainly a
demonstration of what you can do like
every time I run it I'm thinking like oh
if I was to optimize it there's plenty
of better ways to do to do that. Um but
and the the badger and then the other
will be at the end. Um, one of the thing
I'm doing in the code, if I go up, is
that I'm also saving all of the
generated image from the character in a
in an array. And I will explain
afterwards why I'm doing that. And
that's once again just appending them
one after another in in real world. I
would I would save them in a in a better
way. Um,
so and up and the author is here. So now
we can do we can move to the next phase
which is basically illustrating the
book. So uh same thing like I'm going to
ask the the chat uh for each chapter
give me a prompt to illustrate the
what's happening. It should be a single
image not multi one. Uh I'm trying to
force it to describe the character again
even though uh there I will have the
images as references just because it's
it's it's still better. So let's go with
that.
That should be quite fast. Um,
well, same thing like the the the way it
works with charts, it's uh it's keeping
a history that is basically all the
previous messages and it's sending back
the history to to the model every time
we make a we make a call. Um, which can
be like in this case since it's re it's
basically resending the book all the
time to the model. That's that's the
reason why it can be quite slow. Um, we
actually uh released new API a few
months ago that are called the
interactions API. Um, let's run that
while I talk. Um, and and the main
difference between the the new API and
the and the old ones is that the new
APIs are going to be stateful and
stateless. And what what what it changes
is that every time you you make a call,
you get an interactions ID and you can
reuse that interactions ID in future
calls and it will recover all of the all
of the context directly from the server.
So you don't you don't need to re-upload
the same context again and again and
again at every turn of the conversation.
And it's also making it easier to um to
uh to fork the discussion. Uh for
example like you create uh you want to
create a song and with with images and
with a cover image you can create the
lyrics with one model and then you you
you you fork it and on one end you
create the images and the other end you
you create the uh the song you had the
question
>> uh how long you start the session
>> huh
>> how long do you store the session is it
>> um that's a good question I think it's
two days something like that
Um, it's still it's still in uh in
preview. So, uh, but uh there's good
chances that at IO we make it the
default API. Um, but I yeah, I don't I
I'm not using it enough to yeah to know.
One of the cool thing it does as well is
that since it knows that it's context
that you're going to reuse, it's
automatically caching it as well. So, it
makes it cheaper to to run. But even
though those the normal API are also
doing the same but um so we have our
chapter. So the third chapter is next to
the river. So they the mole and the and
the and the forgot his name characters
are together. Then it's on the road
with the with the toad
and then in the forest in the snow. O
scary.
So see and that's uh and and basically
what I what I did there is that I use
the fact that we were using the the
history to uh to to trust the model to
have all of the all of the previous
images of the character so that uh it
would remember uh how they look like and
what's uh and how to uh create new um
images of them.
Um but uh there's actually better ways
to do that. So I tried another way uh
which is basically to create a new um a
new structured output. That is basically
the name of the chapter the prompt but
also the list of the characters that are
appearing in this chapter. And that's
actually what I was doing if I was
wanted to do it at scale with like uh
more than a few characters. And
basically I'm um I'm going to ask the
model to uh to give me a pro for each
chapter but also to give me the uh to
have uh thanks to the list of characters
I will only give it as references the
the right images for the for the
chapter. So I'm going to basically get
the same thing here
up. And so the first in the first image
there should be the mole and the water
rod. In the third one in the second one
Mr. Toad mole water rods gray horse and
and the third one mole and water rat
again. Um, so I created a very dirty uh
script that basically uh search through
the the character images that we that we
saved earlier so that I can give it a
list of characters and it just going to
to give me the list of images to uh to
to give to the model.
Uh did I run it? Yeah. And and basically
I'm going to do the same thing and go to
and generate images for each chapter.
But this time instead of on relying on
chat mode I'm going to use generate
content. So the like unary call but I'm
going to pass it the images that are
from the characters that are
specifically in this uh in this chapter
in this chapter image.
So it should give slightly better
context to the model of about what to um
what to uh what to display and how to
show them.
Um,
let's see if it works better. I think I
and uh like like I said like if I wanted
to do it at scale I would I would have
have a lot of improvement I would do
about that. Uh and one of them would be
that I think I would generate more than
one image for per character. I think I
would have been one portrait image and
then one full uh full uh full body image
and then maybe from the side from the
from the back and ask the model to tell
me which exactly which like how they are
going to be displayed so that I can give
uh give the nano banana exactly the the
the reference we need for the for the
for the generation. So here they are.
Um
and it's more or less the same to be
honest. But uh
except that this time I don't know why
it's uh it seems to be attacking the
mall for some reason.
I don't think that's what the story is
about. It's better you you might know
better than me. Um,
we can check the prompt. What What does
the prompt says? Blah blah blah.
No, it doesn't say anything about
attacking the No, it's rescuing him.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's uh that's basically how you
can uh you can use the um uh use a
model. uh for for those who came the
content I'm showing you can you can you
can open it there and uh it's uh it's a
collab that is about taking a book and
creating uh images and videos to
illustrate the book uh and the
characters. So we went through um
creating prompts for each character and
then generating images for each of those
characters and then creating new prompts
for each chapter and then creating uh
images for the chapters uh using the
reference that we have from the from the
images. If you can't see what I wrote,
it's goo.glecookbook-
illustration.
Um
so uh and then we are going to try to
move to the next phase with the with
videos now. Uh so we are going to use uh
VO to generate uh videos of those uh of
those images. So I'm going to swap to
the bigger model because I can pay for
it. You can you can skip to the stay to
stay with the cheapest one if you don't
want to spend too much. Um, and
basically I'm going to uh just do
exactly like take the last chapter, take
the last image, uh, and and basically
send it the same prompt and the and the
reference image. So that's what I do
here. So when I pass an image to VO,
that's basically use it's going to use
it as the first frame for the video.
Um, and funnily enough, like most of the
most of the like a lot of the training
for video generation model is actually
image generation because I think the
most important part of generating a
video is generating the first frame so
that it knows where to start with and
then what to do with it. Um,
so
>> so what is the best video model? Is it
>> it's uh the one that doesn't have light
or fast? So,
>> so fast is just a faster version of the
>> Yeah, that's
>> even more expensive but faster.
>> Yeah. So, V 3.1 is a is the main view
model and the other ones are basically
uh like smaller versions of it that are
running f slightly faster and like
basically doing less less generation
turns.
Um, yes, I said I was going to repeat
the questions and I forgot the questions
was which one is the faster the the more
the better model among the three.
Um, I guess the doors just opened.
Um,
I'm still very early. So up we can see
where it goes.
>> Wait in
this dreadful place.
>> Oh, thank you, water rat. I thought I
was saved.
>> And and there was sounds. I don't know
if we can we have more songs so we can
see what.
>> Quick, give me your hand. We must get
out of this dreadful place.
>> Oh, thank you, water rat. I thought I
was done for.
>> That's That's not that bad except the
wrong character is speaking. That's the
problem with basically using the same
prompt when you when you create the
videos and the and the audio and the the
image because it doesn't have the extra
content about what exactly is meant to
be happening afterwards.
So that's why I add another I added
another example that is basically we're
going to do the same except we are going
to add one more step that is basically
asking Gemini to come up with a new um a
new prompt just for the just for the
video and to explain what's what's
happening afterwards. So um that's what
I'm did. I'm going to animate this the
this chapter image and can you create a
prompt with view about what's happening
in next few seconds after the initial
image. Um and I'm passing it the im the
last image that it knows exactly where
to start. Um
and while it runs since you we have yet
again new people who came if you want to
follow on your laptop that's uh that's a
link to open the the collab I'm showing.
So goo. /cookbook- illustration
and uh what we're doing what we are
doing at the moment is illustrating um
the book that is called uh will of the
willow something like that um and uh and
creating images and then now videos to
illustrate what's happening in the book.
So, we came up with u with a prone that
is like in a colorful building block
style. A water rat in his uh round brown
face and blue jersey lowers his silver
pistols and offers a reassuring part to
the mole's shoulder. The moles in his
black velvet smoking suit exiles a puff
of white plastic vapors in relief. And
as his pink snot switches,
they turn and begin to walk together
blah blah blah blah blah. What's what's
interesting in the prompt is that I feel
like it's uh it got the the the style of
the book. So the prompt is kind of
written in the same style as the same
oldish style of uh of of speaking as
well. Um
and we can see that it's realized that
uh um it's um it's not attacking the
mole, it's just saving it and and so on.
And um and also what's uh what we can
see from there is that you remember I
set I set some system instruction at the
beginning saying that whenever described
characters it should always try to
describe what they look like and all. So
it added what how they are dressed all
the time. So which also helps with the
character consistency. So let's see if
this one is better.
I think it's better except there's no
there's no discussion.
So you you can try with yourself. Just
be careful. As I said uh earlier, video
generation can be expensive. So don't
don't try it like a 100 times until you
get it. Uh it can be it can be guys.
Then um we have this new uh LIA model
that we shipped two weeks ago. That is
our new music generation model and uh
basically as I said it's just a a model
to which you can give a prompt and it
will come up with uh with a song and uh
and you have two different models. You
have the clip model that is creating 30
second uh music and like I think it's
for four four cents per song and you
have the full song model that is
creating up to 3 minutes uh songs and it
costs like twice as much so 8 cents per
uh per music. U for the sake of the
demonstration here I'm using the clip
model so the fastest one. Um, so we are
going to do to use exactly the same the
same trick as before. So we are going to
have Gemini create the uh the prompts
for the music generation. So uh so I'm
asking it to create uh instrumental
songs for each chapter and to create uh
to create them for lia keep the
consistency between the chapters uh but
at the same times highlighting the
what's what's specific in each chapter
so that they are like I don't want like
three times or four times the same in
the same song. I want different ones for
for each song. And and by the way
something that I forgot to say is that
as as you can imagine like we have like
multiple models we have multiple teams
inside of uh inside of deep mind but
actually all of them are working
together and a big part of the training
data for the gen media models is uh is
being made with the help of Gemini. Uh
so so basically all of our gen media
models are trained with like chrome that
are written by Gemini. So that's also
why Gemini is quite good at at creating
uh prompts for for the for the J media
models because yeah it's uh I've been
trained to to listen to him very well.
So uh it's uh that's that's why this
kind of uh of tricks of having Gemini
write the prompts for you works quite
well and and in any case deep down
there's always a bit of rewriting of
your prompt that are being done by the
gen media models before it's actually
starting to generate just because
otherwise when people are sending like
oneliners they're the the models won't
won't be won't do anything interesting
with a with a oneliner and um so usually
the longer your prompt, the more
interesting it's going to be and the
more likely it's going to be following
what you're um what you're asking for.
So, I think I talked a lot because it's
uh like music generation is actually
quite fast. So, we can see the different
songs.
I think that fits with a pastoral suit.
uh with representing spring and flowing
waters
and see next one the open road
feels more adventurous. Yes.
And then the dark forest. Let's see.
Well, and you can see you can see the
prompt here like it it comes with which
uh which um instruments to use, how to
use them. Um, what's what's interesting
with the LIA model is that it's actually
you everything is managed in the prompt.
You don't have that you don't you don't
have parameters at all at the moment.
So, if you want the song to be a certain
duration, you can just ask in the
prompt. If you want the song to be using
a certain scale, you can ask it in the
prompt. If you want certain BPM, you ask
in in the prompt as well. And the model
is really good at understanding
everything you ask in the prompt. And
you can ask like doesn't make sense for
30 second songs uh much but like if you
you're building longer song you can you
can say during the first 30 seconds
that's what I want the songs to be and
then you switch to something else after
uh or you can say this is the intro this
is the outro this is the uh always
forget how to say that in English but
the the part that that is coming up
multiple times in the song so that it
knows exactly how to chorus chorus
Um this knows that this part needs to be
repeated and that it needs to be the
same thing and same model. And if you
want uh lyrics, you can either provide
the lyrics or um or uh
or just uh let it in invent lyrics. So
let's say we are going to change that.
We are going to create uh songs with
chapter um add lyrics.
to describe
what's happening
up
in the chapter.
And let's see how it goes with lyrics
this time.
As I said, music generation is quite
fast like especially the 30 secondond
model takes a few sec to to generate
things. The the longer uh part here is
actually sending sending the book again
to the model and to ask it for
for prompts.
I think it didn't
I think it didn't work.
Mole and
Mole flung down his brush and ran to the
sun
away from the cleaning
and work to be done.
and see this one.
>> Dreamed of the dusty high roads ahead.
>> And like you can see that the the theme
of the songs is quite the same. That's
kind of the the price we have to pay for
using chat mode because it remembers the
prompt it did before. So we ask for new
prompts, but it still has the memory of
of what it did before. So I think it
kind of anchored it to kind of use the
same kind of prompt and describe the
scene the same way. Uh but still it's
it's very funny to to work with the
lyrics and you as you can see in the
prompt, it's basically just like adding
the lyrics in the prompt and the model
understand that this these are the
lyrics I need to I need to play and and
add in the song. Uh and you can also say
that this this specific uh part uh this
is is said at exactly this moment in the
in the song. This part is uh is is um is
being said at another moment. And if you
check the output of the LAA model, you
actually have the old lyrics with the
times. So you can create a karaoke app
or something like that using what you
get from out of the model. Let's let's
try the third one. into the wild wood
where the shadows are deep and evil
faces through the hollow trees peep.
Mole is in terror and lost in the snow
till Ratty arrives with his pistols a
glow.
We could do uh we could do musical with
that.
Um, so that's that's for music
generation. And then um we have uh we
also have a text uh generation models
and I'm going to show you something uh
very fun. I guess you all know about the
our texttospech
model because everybody loved the uh
notebook lm integration that can create
um uh a podcast and and that's actually
great that you can select two different
voices. So you have to have two two
characters talking with each other. But
I'm going to show you a trick that uh
with which you can actually create
something that is basically uh you you
can add more characters than actually
two when you are creating uh discussions
with the TTS model. So here's what I'm
going to do. Uh I'm going to ask the
model to extract a specific dialogue
from the from the book just because I
didn't want to copy paste it. Um, so I
told it that it starts with small neat
ears and and thick silky ear and ends
with his ears in the air. Um, but and I
asked it to write it as a play so that
it's basically a transcript of which
which which what which character should
be should be saying. And the and the
trick is that I'm asking it to create a
specific style of of way of speaking for
each character even though it's going to
be using the same voice and to and to
write the transcript that way. So when
it's a narrator, I'm going to use one
specific voice and when it's all of the
other character is going to be the same
voice for all of them. Um so nar so
narrator is saying something and then
character is saying something and then
write the style between parenthesis and
that's what is going to tell the model
how to how to how to talk and that's
that's something that you can also use
to say oh it is saying this part very
like whispering and then this part is
like has a lot of emotion in it and you
can you can play with the way the
character talks but I'm I'm going to uh
use that to ask the model to come up
with very different ways for from the
same voice to to uh to talk when each
character is talking. And that's
actually creates uh the feeling of
actual different voices for for each of
them.
So, and then I'm going to pass that to
the TTS model and to uh and to ask it to
to read it basically. Uh one of the
trick and like I got I I lost 15 minutes
about because of that yesterday evening.
So this you cannot just give it the text
to read. You always have to start with
read this text or something like that
otherwise it for some reason it doesn't
know that it needs to read the text that
is giving it given to it. Um and uh this
is a very complex uh I think there's no
simple way to to set it up but basically
what I say is speaker narrator is using
the the voice uh Sulafat and character
is using Fenrier
and this is all text so narrator talks
then character the first character talk
and that's uh is going to have long
poetic poses and then the second one is
breathless uh and uh stutter And you can
see that we can we can guess which
character is which one because it's the
same way of speaking that is reused for
each of those lines
and it's still running. The problem uh
with the TTS model is that it's a very
good model but it's not a very fast one.
Um the reason for that is that
>> small neat ears and thick silky hair. It
was the water rat. Then the two animals
stood and regarded each other
cautiously.
>> Hello, Mole.
>> Hello, rat.
>> Would you like to come over?
>> Oh, it's all very well to to talk. The
rat said nothing, but stooped and
unfassened a rope and hold on it, then
lightly stepped into a little boat which
the mole had not observed. The rat
sculled smartly across and made fast.
Then he held up his forpaw as the mole
stepped gingerely down.
>> Lean on that
>> now. Then step lively.
>> The mole to his surprise and rapture
found himself actually seated in the
stone of a real boat.
>> This has been a a wonderful day. Do you
know I've never never been in a boat
before in all my life?
>> What? Never been in a You never Well, I
What have you been doing then?
>> Is it Is it so nice as all that?
>> We can stop that. like you you you can
you can see you you couldn't guess that
we're using the same voice for for the
two characters being like they clearly
were uh steered into different
directions and you can use this trick to
actually uh create like multiple
characters multiple voices for those
characters and uh and make it seems like
seamless for for for users. As I said uh
earlier, this is meant to be just
demonstration on how to do it. If you
want to if you were to do to to do it
like uh at scale, that's ex that I would
not do this kind of like create trick
like that. I would actually create a
full transcript with the actual names
and then keep on the side a prompt for
each character. And maybe sometimes you
still want to uh you you don't want to
talk them exactly the same way because
sometimes they still need to be excited
even though they talk very slow and and
so on. But still that's uh that's uh
that's just to show how good the the TTS
model is at creating uh different
voices. And even though I asked it to
force an accent, it didn't it didn't do
it. But you can also play with like this
character has an Irish accent, this one
is English, this one speak uh with a
German accent or whatever. And that's
that's also a very easy way to uh to
create different feeling about the about
the character for with using the same
voice.
Um we're nearly at time for the for the
questions but like uh just to finish
like uh we we use a very large context
window of the model uh to to fit it a
full book and to fit it multiple times a
full book because with chat we we just
uh upload it all the time. But since
it's uh it's a multi multimodel in model
you can you just it's work with other
things than just text. So you can just
fill it like an audio book. uh you can f
it a uh video as well like you can play
with that and not just get get limited
to uh to text to uh to illustrate on
things. So this is another example with
uh with another book which one which is
uh the adventures of chatter the red
squill and and we are basically going to
do the same thing. I'm going to run all
of it at the same time.
Uh, and this time I basically ask it uh
somewhere
uh to use a style that is futuristic,
science fiction, utopia, saturated, neon
lights. So, it's going to be not the
kind of squirrel you are expecting, you
know.
Um, yeah. And while it runs, I think,
uh, oh, I said I was going to show you.
Um so we also have like I think you all
know about AI studio but uh in Audio we
have a gallery with lots of uh example
apps that we are building and I wanted
to show you uh it's going to be in gen
media
uh as I told you we have the model that
is creating music uh songs we but we
also have the
uh no not this one let's let's go with
the
up. This one's better. We also have the
Lia real time model I was talking about
and and basically you are asking it to
create to to make music that is postpunk
tunes and new song at the same time.
But you can say, "Okay, I want more
K-pop
and slightly more drums.
I don't know what post punk is, so I
don't want it."
See, you can hear the music changing.
And let's go with something like more
chill.
So I think as I said that's my favorite
model because I think it's underused and
I I like there's plenty of things I I
can imagine doing like as I said I come
from the video game industry so one of
the things I would have tried is can you
create music in real time for the player
depending on like where in which region
they are in are they in the forest? Are
they jumping? Are they cooking? Are they
fighting? Uh how much HP do they have?
And so so the music could change in real
life in real time.
And so that's uh yeah, that's kind of
things you can try. And uh for some
reason the link is not there, but
there's another very cool example our
colleagues were working on this model
made. It's basically uh you are in space
and each planet is a prompt and you can
move through the planet and depending on
which planet you are close to the music
changes. So you can just move around the
planets and sometimes there are weird
things happening because like Christmas
songs is just next to Viking metal. So
uh the the mix can be can be quite
funny.
Um so that's it for the for the
presentation. I have some time for
questions now.
Thank you.
Yeah. And for those who arrive too late
like you can you can check the the
content afterwards. And as I said uh we
have this this cookbook that is
basically a GitHub repo where we are
adding uh quick starts on how to use the
models uh uh kind of some some tricks
and also examples of uh like uh more
complex uh more complex things you can
build when you are mixing different
capabilities and models.
>> Question I don't know if you can answer
it but
>> yeah I think for questions we need mic
so that's it. I don't need to repeat
them.
One, two, one, two, one, two, one, two,
one, two.
>> So, thank you first of all very much for
this nice demo. It was a lot of fun to
follow along. I have a question. Um in
our company we um offering to all
employees um also some of of models and
I think we are still on nano banana one
because we can only offer models hosted
in the in Europe and basically all the
new models are still in preview so we
don't have access to it. Do you know
>> if this will change?
>> So uh the short answer is no.
>> Okay. Uh but I like I was expecting the
question because I like it's it's a pain
for everyone in in Europe. As I as I
said, my job is to bring the feedback
from the developers and to try to make
things change. So that's that's part of
the one of the fights I'm fighting at
the moment. Uh so that we uh we have
some some ways to offer a better uh exit
for for or better ways to use a model
for for people in Europe because uh in
Europe we care about uh like data
privacy and data sovereignty and all of
that. So I know it's a it's a problem.
Um so the the the core of the problem in
a way it's the rule that at Google cloud
that uh every preview model is only
available on global endpoints. Um so
that's uh is unlikely to change but what
we are going to try to change is to
release the model in global
accessibility uh faster. the the problem
we have we had with Nano Banana 2 and
Pro and uh and like Gemini 3.3 as well
is that we release models too quickly
back to back and so instead of like
having Gemini 3 going GA we released
Gemini 3.1 and so we like kind of reset
the the pre the the preview counter uh
so that's uh we we need to we need to
make to do something about that but yeah
I I know I I hear you it's kind of my P
zero thing that I want to change. Um,
>> thank you.
>> And like have you have you run the
notebook at the same time?
>> Yes.
>> Which style where do you Oh, wow.
Did someone else run it at the same time
and with a different style and or maybe
a different book?
>> Um,
>> no. I I did the Frankenstein book.
>> Oh.
>> And choose like the lead to G.
>> Sure.
>> So So I did the Frankenstein book and
choose like a retro gaming style and was
quite interesting. So um yeah. So the
character looked very video game like
>> Oh yeah.
And um yeah, the the main difficulty
with uh with books like Frankenstein is
that sometimes the model is not going to
be uh allowing to things that are too
like let's say graphic that could be
happening in the book. So uh it can be a
bit toned down or worse it's not going
to uh to accept uh to show the image. Um
yeah that's why I settled with kids
books for the for the example. that's
easier
except when I was not able to uh make
images of of children's which was also
another limiting factor.
Um
yeah I can show you other I don't know
what's page afterwards is going to show
I can show you other cool demos that we
have related to J media.
Um, in the meantime, if you have
questions, just, uh, raise your hand
and, uh, and we can
uh,
we're going back here.
See, that's, uh,
whatever. Uh, that's the, uh, futuristic
neon style version of, uh, of Chatter,
the the squirrel.
Um
I can show you um bit more about Lea
because it's new and uh you likely
already know everything about Nano
Banana um
up. So as I said earlier when you work
with um with LIA the you always get uh
two outputs. If you if you set the
modalities to be uh their audio and text
you will get two outputs and the first
output is going to be the the lyrics and
the second output is going to be the
music. Um and that's actually one of the
few model where it's very interesting to
use uh streaming. So when you do
generate content here, you can use
generate content underscore stream and
what it does that you receive the first
part first and then the second part
afterwards. So you get the lyrics first.
So if you want to do something according
to the lyrics like creating an image or
uh like giving a the song a title, then
you can do it while the music is uh is
still generating and you don't have to
wait for the full output to be to be
there.
So you get the you get the lyrics and
you get the timing. So the this um this
sentence is going to be said at the
beginning and then after 4.8 sec it's
going to say something else and so on.
So you can you can
>> still up here
the mountain tops are sharp and clear
and then a streak of gent.
So yeah and then you can do and you can
provide the same thing and here it's
only like you can see the last one it's
providing when it starts and when it
ends because it wants to have like 1.2
two second without uh without things
said at the end.
Um up you can also create images from uh
music from images. So that's one of the
thing I forgot to do in uh in today's
demo. I I should have also gave the the
the images from the from the chapter so
that it would have been used uh as a
reference to create the image. So I use
this picture of like grocery list for
for making a porter and then it will
come up with a song about doing a photo.
What was the prompt again? An epic song
with opera voices about this quest.
See it's becoming epic.
The scrolls are dry. The ink is ancient.
The list is long. The soul is patient.
Beef shank and ribs. The holy prize in
the cellar where the shadow lies.
>> And that's so also nice that you can use
multiple voices as well.
I'm going to skip ahead a bit.
The time is the
salary. The end is near. The final
moment of the quest is here.
I like
>> so but then um and I I talked about the
interactions API earlier about being our
new uh ways of using the API. So that's
an example using those. So it basically
was the same as the current API. Um so
you give a model, you give an input and
you get respons modalities. Uh yeah,
Philip who worked on that is not there
so I can say it. I would not have
renamed uh uh content to input because
it's going to confuse everybody but
that's how it is. Um and then you get
the output and uh um and if we can check
in the output I think no uh yeah we
don't we don't see it here but there's
uh and then it works basically the same
way except you get this uh interactions
ID that you can use to uh to chain
things.
Um and then that's uh yeah that's the
one with images and prompting. Um what
you can do as well is you can use the
BPM part. So you can you want a song
that is very fast or very slow. So
that's that we use this
and I even told it to use a reset
accidental illusion. So it gives the the
illusion that the music is getting
faster and faster and faster.
So if you want music for when you do
your sports routine that's uh how you
go.
And as I said you can give like a
specific time. So the first 10 seconds
are going to be fast acoustic guitar and
then it goes into piano for 20 sec for
10 more sec and then it's full band
afterwards. So
actually it's not following it.
Okay. Okay, forgot forgot what I just
saw showed
for some reason. And then but the
easiest way is like this. You can use uh
you can give the structure. So that's
how I want my intro. That's how I want
my verse. That's what I want my outro.
And that's 30 second song. So it's not
like you won't have the chorus, but you
can also add the chorus and the bridge
and so on. So um
>> what is that about? Oh yes, the sunset.
Dawn's triumphant
call.
A golden light, a glorious sight.
Chasing night with heaven.
Our heartsound.
>> Yeah, I need to make made a better
longer song, I think, for example. And
but you can also chain all of that into
uh like everything together. So this is
a full song where uh from from the first
two second I have an intro. I I can tell
exactly which uh which scale to use, how
intense it's going to be and then it
moved to another verse and so on and so
on. And that's u how you can get
something very uh complex.
So it starts very very slow and then if
we move
the drums uh and bus started and so on.
So we should be in this part. It's still
laidback
and
and starting to be yeah to add grooves
and so on. So if you if you want to
create complex things, it's better to
use a full song model because it's uh
the the short one is taking shortcuts to
actually build something that is
interesting in 30 seconds.
And as as I already showed, you can
provide the lyrics. So, it's creating a
song about nano bananas.
>> Yellow
banana
treat it hums. It starts to create
a mode.
>> Um,
but uh and and what's what's funny as
well is that you can use it to create
things that are basically not not uh
songs. So you can uh you can ask it to
create uh music but without with very
calm music in the background and just
some something reading a text or or or
something like that. So this and this
one I'm using the reasoning capabilities
of the model to and its knowledge about
what Shakespeare is doing and so to to
create a text that is basically
>> something that looks like my life
and all my glories to the grave must go.
Oh, heavy grace to be at last at peace.
And
>> grant my weary soul a sweet release.
>> And I didn't really tell it to read, so
that's why there's still music, but you
can you can really steer it into not
having background music at all and uh
and just say things. And you it works
also in different languages. So you can
uh you can just ask it to uh to uh to
create songs in all languages that you
want. Sometimes there are few words that
are not pronounced the right way. It's
still it's it's still getting better.
And this one I try to ask to uh to use
two different languages in the same
song. And since it's the same as the TTS
and live models that we have, it's
really good at switching uh switching
the the language in the middle of the of
the generation.
And once again, I'm using the model
knowledge of things because it's
basically trying to explain how bubble
sword is working in music
>> um and instruments. You you saw it. So
yeah, there's plenty of very cool things
to uh to build with with the model. So
give give it a try. It's uh it's very
easy to use and because everything is in
the prompt. So yeah.
Do you have any other question?
No. What do you want uh Paige to show
you afterwards?
>> She has she has seven more minutes to
prepare something new in our in our
presentation.
>> True. And also just for clarification,
I'm not sure if this was announced to
the uh to all of y'all. Um but there are
selectable issues in the building. Um,
so there y'all are like the lucky
valiant few that made it here earlier
this morning. Um, the most of the
attendees were not allowed into the
building. Um, and so uh the we'll do the
session that's coming up at 10:40, but
we'll also be bringing back everybody in
the afternoon who is going to be
presenting in the morning to do kind of
like a a whistle stop tour of all of the
Google Dive things for the afternoon
workshop. So, if you would prefer to
come back for the afternoon workshop,
you can. It'll just be at 1 p.m.
>> So, and that was the example I was
talking about. I just I don't know where
Christmas songs are, but uh
>> how can you drive us by?
>> It just search for Space DJ and it's
available online.
Can you move the to put the sounds
higher?
That would be nice.
>> So the more is not meant to do voices,
but it can do some kind of like
vocalizations like that.
He bought
a lot of break.
It was not that bad at using the same
voice and switching the style of music
together.
>> And you have an autopilot, so it just
moves around and it music.
>> Yeah. Sound rock.
Nashville songs.
>> Yeah, it's not putting fast enough.
turn. Oh, turn tables.
>> Australian epoch, I guess.
>> No, no Australian here.
Um, yeah, that's uh that's a really cool
model. And uh the only thing is that the
session ends after 10 minutes. So that
you so you have to run it uh at at the
time. But uh like in theory it should
work.
Let's
>> just missing
speed.
So, I will stop with that. But yeah,
give it give it a try. It's a really
cool model to play with.
Um,
okay.
So, yeah, I guess that's it. I will
still be around if you have other
questions, things you want to discuss
that you didn't want to be on camera.
So,
yeah.
Thank you.